sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
platform and the best place to buy your
bitcoin
hey guys anna welcome back to the leia
hill plan show so i am so excited to do
this show today because unfortunately it
is looking pretty red there's a lot of
blood in the streets right now and we
have a great guest to go through all of
this and trying to make some sense of it
and figure out where things are going
but before i do bring him on um i want
to say a huge thank you to bit mex
because bitmex are my brand new sponsor
this month and without them we wouldn't
be able to bring you such valuable
content so bitmex are a crypto exchange
and as of may 17th they're actually
launching a brand new spot exchange to
easily and instantly buy and sell your
assets so to celebrate they're giving
away one million dollars in crypto to
spot traders over the next few months so
this is actually one of the biggest
giveaways in crypto right now so if you
do want to enter i'm going to leave the
link for more information in the
description for you um it's gonna be
really exciting there's a lot of
different assets that you can start
trading so definitely go check them out
and a huge thank you to bitmex all right
guys let's get things going joining me
today is the one and only ran nuna the
host of the extremely popular crypto
banter youtube show let's bring ran on
hey ran how are you it's pretty hectic
out there right now
let's just say i've had better days i
mean if that's uh let's say i've had
better days i mean i don't think it's
any big secret to anyone that luna was
my biggest bag
i was absolutely irresponsibly long i
did publicize that um
and it went wrong and today i'm dealing
with the consequences i think it's going
to be a fan show it's going to be a very
personal show i think it's going to be
great i'm actually right now tweeting
telling people to join us on my channel
amazing
amazing so luna luna was your biggest
bag um so that is absolutely insane you
were irresponsibly long um can you give
us an idea of how much you've lost and
is this overnight
i'm not gonna talk numbers um because
the problem is if i talk numbers i'm
opening myself up for crazy stupid
attacks but let me just give you the
history of my history with luna so that
you understand where i came from i met
dokwan and danny um oh who define who
are the founders of luna in the hashed
incubator in 2017 when i was the first
western journalist with cnbc 2017 or
2018 i was the first western journalist
to go to um to korea and cover the
crypto scene there in this in korea
there was a
fund called hasht
and hashed had an accelerator inside the
accelerator some of the best companies
came out of there and one of these
companies was this young company called
tara luna and they were working on a on
a amazing stable coin they're working on
an algorithmic stablecoin and when i
once i left them i was so impressed with
the guys that i ended up investing i
landed up i ended up investing quite a
big portion a manual like a couple
hundred thousand in the audio in ico and
i always held the position
and you know when luna was going was at
26 cents and 27 cents and 28 cents i
kept buying more and more and more and
more and more
and
then of course that bag exploded
and because luna was such an amazing
ecosystem and we really thought that it
was going to be the next algorithmic
the future of money i mean an
algorithmic stable coin
which was something completely new a
novel
um i invested very heavily in the
ecosystem around it so it's almost like
you know if you believe in the ethereum
chain and you invest in you know
compound and rv and all the things that
are being built on the chain so i
invested in indexes and i invested in
the meta versus and i invested in the
anchor protocol and i invested in all of
those things um
to the point where you know it was
irresponsibly one of my biggest bags and
i actually did a very public stream
where i said like you know i'm
irresponsibly long it's one of my
biggest bags and it's time for me to
start exiting and over a period of time
i'm going to start exiting my bag and i
did i mean i did i started exiting into
solana and i started exiting into
avalanche and engineer but i didn't do
it fast enough and the reason why i
didn't do it fast enough was a
combination of two things
the first thing is greed
when you have a protocol that you are
emotionally attached to and it's
bringing you such incredible returns
you don't want to let it go
and i kept fighting it and moving it
into other things other things knowing
that i was doing it but again
too slow and i mean the second mistake
is that
i wasn't resolute because if i was
resolute what i should have said is hold
on
this is now 70 of your portfolio
get the [ __ ] out
make it 30 of your portfolio and cut it
today
and i didn't do that because you know
you always think that you have the
luxury of time i think in the bull
market we all always thought we had the
luxury of time that you know the bull
market's only going to end when there's
a blow off top and one thing that i've
learned having experienced three very
very good and very bad markets in crypto
is
the bull market always ends way way way
sooner than you expect
and the bear market always lasts way way
way longer than you expect
and that's that's the truth of it and
every time we think it's going to be
different
and every time we try and convince
ourselves that this time is going to be
different or maybe we even try to
convince ourselves that this time was
going to be the same we were going to
have that blow off top we were going to
have that fourth cycle where we were
going to have that blow off top and then
it would be the end of the book and it
wasn't
so
you know you learn lessons as i said on
my stream today
today's been one of the hardest days of
my life uh in fact so hard that i
thought of cancelling on you but after
last week losing my voice i thought if i
cancelled you again you'll never go for
dinner with me so then i thought you
know let me let me do this and actually
let me use this opportunity to be
authentic and really share
my experience and my learnings uh being
on the other side of the microphone
because usually i'm the one interviewing
another one in
and now this time i've got someone who
is as great and as professional as you
on the other side who can maybe
get it get this out there and get people
listening to this
so you said that you know you met the
guys you liked the project um you know
you were investing on you on the way up
you took a little bit of profit but
because of greed obviously you you
didn't sell as much as as much as you
should have done so the question is
what went wrong you know if you how do
people avoid this next time you know
like you met the guys you trusted them
how do people avoid this moving forward
it's very tough because
a couple of things the first thing is we
all drink the kool-aid every single day
like we drink crypto kool-aid every
single day now theoretically someone can
come to you and say to you like you know
like let's put the [ __ ] aside
you really want me to put money into a
digital coin that i can't touch and feel
that is completely decentralized you
really want me dead now we've bought the
kool-aid and we believe in it and a lot
of these concepts that we believe in are
actually going to work
but some of them are not going to work
and what we've got to acknowledge is
that every single one of these things is
an experiment
and experiments when you're trying to do
new things experiments are going to fail
and you know when experiments are going
to fail
experiments are going to fail
when they
get stress tested
by
by the hardest and toughest of external
forces
and then we're really gonna know if
these experiments played out and
let me give you the example of luna for
example
so
luna
now
was it's an algorithmic base table in
other words it's backed by nothing
and i think what they did was they made
a fundamental mistake
the fundamental mistake is what made
them heroes the fundamental mistake is
they said look we're going to take this
algorithmic animal coin
and in order to avoid this thing called
the death spiral and the death spiral is
when people sell their ust
and
it depends and then because it depicts
more and more and more people sell their
ust because you don't want to be part of
a sinking ship
so
because it's not actually backed by
anything
people made the call to tap out and it's
like
we're tapping others
and
let's talk about where it actually went
wrong
so dokwan
who is a very very very smart guy
one of the smartest guys i've ever met
also one of the nicest guys i've ever
met that like i might say that even
after all of this and all the money that
i've lost and he's been you could say
quite arrogant and he's displayed hubris
and and all the traits that we don't
like we can talk about that later on in
the show
he made some massive mistakes
the first mistake is i think he got
caught up in the hype and i think he
loved being
the king
of the community and you know like when
the bitcoin holders embraced him
and like wow he bought bitcoin and oh
there's a new bitcoin bar in town
he it got him and he made a mistake the
mistake was that he started to announce
his purchases now have you ever heard in
wall street
people announce their purchases
no absolutely not you don't say i'm
going to buy tesla because the rest of
the market's going to front run you
the other thing that he announced which
was which is catastrophic in my event
was he said
we will protect the pig at 0.98
so when the peg gets to 0.98 when the
stable coin starts devaluing to 0.98
that is when we will start deep
defending the pick
and then wall street was listening to
this and they said hold on a second
you're going to defend the pack at 0.98
you've also told us you've got 3 billion
worth of bitcoin
but we have 5 billion dollars
so let us like get a bit of panic going
and we have more money than you said
we'll just bully you and destroy you and
go short on your on your token and and
that's exactly what happened wall street
basically we we we think we suspect
allegations i don't want to be sued for
being on this podcast
that wall street
uh coordinated an attack against crypto
and you know for wall street
um
they don't see anything but an
opportunity they don't see people they
don't see the new economy they're not
here for that they're here so that they
can attack
they can
do the normal moves that they do on
hitch the hedge fans do every single day
they're going to do them here i mean
we've all seen the movie billions and it
was highly entertaining and the parts
that were the most highly entertaining
was
when there were sophisticated attacks
that were done which were
pretty smart and you know they sold
something and they went short and it
completely collapsed and then they
bought it up and it went up again
and they just did it this time so crypto
protocol
and
as i said earlier on my show i said
on the one hand we want wall street's
money in crypto because that's going to
bring real money into crypto and real
money is going to drive up the prices
but when you invite wall street to
crypto
you get the money but you also get
everything else that comes with it
and everything else that comes with it
is
that you're not getting these experts
who have a shitload of cash i mean
under the assumption that this was
ken griffith and and king griffin and
citadel which is there sometimes an
assumption
he personally is worth 26 billion
dollars
okay you needed four billion dollars you
needed less than a billion dollars to
collapse this whole lunar thing
for him it's like
it's like come like really we're looking
down really okay let me just
just just probably had a junior trader
executing it you know that that's that's
how poor it was
and
so that's i mean those are those are you
know some of the valuable some of the
most valuable lessons like as a person
don't get attached to a token
and i think crypto as crypto people
we're super super super guilty of that
we're
we're attached to protocols
almost like cults you know you try and
and and attack the xrp community or say
something not so nice about cardano
or or
we're you know and what that shows
is that you're emotionally attached and
you know like
you take a and i'm using cardano as a
as a um as an example but they're many
like this
in crypto but you take a cardano holder
and even if the chain breaks tomorrow
they'll find a way to justify that it's
not the end of the world yes because
we're emotionally attached
and so that's one you know like because
we're so emotionally attached and we can
go through why we're emotionally
attached if you want in a second because
i've worked i've worked this all out
um
it is
so ultimately that that's the problem
you do become emotionally attached
so what do we do when you know people
love the idea of having this
decentralized so-called decentralized
stable coin amazing yields especially
because all the centralized exchanges
have now slashed their rates
um so do you think we're ever going to
get to a point where we have a truly
reliable decentralized stable coin or
would you say
given a lot of them our experiments
bitcoin is really the only thing we can
truly rely on
so bitcoin isn't is is
bitcoin is
certainly right now the only thing that
we can rely on because everything else
is an experiment
and to an extent we can say that bitcoin
is an experiment
and the experiment has withstood the
most attacks out of any of the other
experiments and has become bigger and
stronger and the bigger something
becomes obviously
the less that can break it that's just
the nature of how things work
i mean if you wanted to be critical you
could say
there are some attacks that bitcoin
hasn't yet withstood like an all-out
government attack okay like like a
government buying i don't know whatever
i'm just giving an example like we
haven't had we've had governments ban
mining and whatever but there are a
couple we haven't
and so even though i want to say that
bitcoin can never be broken
let's agree that there is a greater than
zero percent chance that bitcoin can
break
can be attacked we don't know about what
but it can be attacked they just agree
that there is a probability even if it's
zero comma one percent
as you move down the the crypto
hierarchy
the attacks become easier and easier to
execute
um
ethereum is much harder easier to attack
than bitcoin and you know if you if you
work your way down all the the attacks
become much better
so
you ask the question about whether or
not we can get a decentralized stable
coin
so far we haven't proven that we can get
a decentralized algorithmic stable coin
i mean you can have a collateralized
stable coin
you know uh maker does probe die and
make it has probably shown us that we
can have a collateral stable coin
but then
the other thing is you talk about these
insane yields
now the insane yields that you talk
about are probably 20 and you're
probably talking about the 20 that was
available on anchor protocol right
yeah
but that was a marketing that was
marketing that was marketing that is
if i were to say to you that you could
either you could either run commercials
on tv for the adoption of anchor
protocol or of ust or what you could do
is you could tell people that you have
this protocol and you could take all of
your marketing budget and you could put
it into a fake high yield
which was gonna be fake for just long
enough to get adoption of the coin and
then you're gonna start pulling it back
and actually recently what they did was
actually started pulling it back it used
to be 20
and then it became 18
and then they were going to reduce that
i think to 16.5
and they were going to continue to do it
up until a certain point
so
that is the
that is the um
the it was just it was just a marketing
well not gonna say scheme cause scheme
is a bad word it was marketing to get
people to use a stable coin and that's
exactly what happened
yeah i think we see that across uh the
board in general um you know your loyal
loyal customers getting getting the
getting the brunt of it unfortunately um
but the market in general you know
before um before all of this happened is
absolutely chaotic bitcoin um thirty
thousand dollars everything is just down
even the s p 500 everything is just
crashing so what is your opinion why are
we in
this
somewhat bear market which is also just
not exclusive to crypto
okay so uh if you allow me i want to
share my screen and i wanted to show you
let me show you a few things so the
first thing that i want to show you is
the nasdaq i want to show you three
charts and i want to give you some
perspective because you're saying that
everything is collapsing and it's you
know you you're kind of making it sound
like you know we're pretty much like
this is a very very very bad collapse
and i've always been taught that when
you think something like that all you
need to do just very quickly
is zoom out a little bit
okay i'm going to zoom you out to before
covert that's that's where we were
before covert okay that's that little
spot over there
and then i'm going to show you where we
are
right now after this terrible collapse
uh two years later we're 25 percent up
which is kind of like not a bad return
if for a stock market in
if it's not a bad return for a stock
market in two years
now i want to give you another i want to
show you another uh i want to show you
another example
um
let me just show you we're just get i'm
going to do the same thing on a bitcoin
chart
and i'm going to take you to pre-covered
levels
yeah there we go so so you've got uh
covered wise 2020 right so here we go
pre-covered levels
you were at
10 000 a coin and now you've it's three
x your return and you're telling me that
we're in a massive crash
you know like it's all about perspective
so so let's get some perspective the
markets were extremely overheated
and now the markets are coming back to
some kind of rationality
as part of a normal market cycle
and
the market cycle will correct itself
right now the united states is is
is dealing with unprecedented inflation
and
they they created the inflation by
printing money
and as i said in a tweet once i said
the fed give us and the fed take us away
you know they they gave they gave us the
money and now they're taking it away and
that's pretty much you know that's
that's that's what happened
so yeah i mean i think this is a normal
normal correction i'm not panicked about
it in any in any way whatsoever i think
the future for bitcoin is bright the
future for markets is bright the fed
needs the markets to relax that
inflation can calm down so that ordinary
americans can live a normal a normal
life
um i don't i don't want to say another
thing which most people aren't taking
into account like
hell it's so cool to make money in the
markets i love making money in the
markets whether it's in the stock market
it's the crypt i love making money on
the markets
but making money on the markets is not
so cool when
your favorite car costs you three times
what it cost you and when your favorite
uh i don't know a restaurant cost you
three times what it would cost you
inflation is a serious thing
it is a serious thing to to everybody
except the top one percent of society
who who don't really care about their
living expenses and their luxuries right
if you've got a billion dollars whether
your car costs a hundred thousand
dollars or 150 000 doesn't actually
really matter to you like it doesn't
matter you know you don't really curse
it
for everyone else the difference between
a hundred and thousand dollars or 150
000
is ludicrous it's stupid it's ridiculous
and they can't live like that
so you've got to think from the point of
view of governments regulators and even
from 99.9 percent of the population
the main priority is actually to get
inflation under control
even if the top one percent of us don't
make as much money on the markets for a
year or two or 12 months or six months
you've got to get inflation under
control because if you have spiraling
inflation and the reason why i know this
so well
is because i live in south africa and in
south africa we have periods where the
currency we had periods where the
currency halved so like one day
it was seven to the dollar and the next
day was 14th the dollar and then all of
a sudden
like everything doubles in price and
then your money is actually worthless
i cannot
the reality is that very few people can
tap out of the system and go to bitcoin
right and
maybe you're one of the few that
actually has completely tapped out i
certainly
have tried to but i haven't tapped out
completely i've still got fiat related
assets i still drive a car in a house
and i still have some earnings in fiat
and those fiat earnings are getting like
worse and worse and worse so ultimately
this is part of a market cycle we
shouldn't panic the markets there's
nothing systematically wrong there's
just too much money and they're going to
start taking it out the markets and then
the markets will continue to grow
because that's what markets do and
that's just what it is
yeah that's a good way to put it now
there's nothing systematically wrong
this is the way market cycles work so
what would your advice be to people
right now so
it looks like we're in a bear market um
do you have a kind of time frame um i
know people often say the four year
cycles are finished
um so is your advice right now to start
researching different projects would it
be to stack sats what's the advice
i think um
always deck sets always always always
deck
um
but don't be irresponsible in the way
that you stack stats because
what you realized is that that you know
what i realized certainly is that
everything here is an experiment i
really believe in bitcoin i've i have
more money in bitcoin than any token
than any asset than anything in my life
i have more money in bitcoin so let's
just use that as the the base starting
point right
um but that's it hey it can't fail you
don't want to be all in on bitcoin
especially if you've got other
responsibilities you it can you can't
fail it can fail i'm not saying it will
i hope it won't i probably won't but
there is a very small chance that it's
going to fill and when it does it's
going to be like luna it's going to go
to zero on one day you know it's not
going to be a halfway if it fails for
whatever the reason of the failure is
and i don't think it will fail it's
going to go to zero in one day
um how long but i don't think it's going
to happen i think we're going to be in a
bull market and crypto is going to take
over the world just to be clear how long
is this bear market going to last
unfortunately because of luna i think
that this bear market is going to last
longer than we think
and i'll tell you why
we
since i've been in crypto
and that's 2015 we've never had a
tier one level one protocol that has
been with a vibrant ecosystem with a
huge wide ecosystem
and multiple projects built on it with
multiple vcs invested in both the
ecosystem and the projects with multiple
lp's money
collapse we've never had that before
we've never had an ethereum collapse or
an xrp collapse
never happened before
now it's happened and a lot of people
lost a lot of money on luna and a lot of
them lost money that they ordinarily
wouldn't have
and these are crypto believers
so people who you know they always say
it's easy to get a customer to keep one
of your own customers and to get an
outside customer these are our own
customers these are our people who are
now out out blown blown
i had a guy in my office yesterday
who when this happened he borrowed him
his wife sold her business
she sold it for she had half a million
quid
he
took the money without telling her
and invested it into crypto
and
well some of it was in luna a lot of it
was india and lunar orlando project and
it went to zero
okay now look i know that's probably
very very very irresponsible
but it happens and we've all been
irresponsible because we're human
because that's just who we are
and so what i'm saying is i think that
unfortunately this collapse of luna
is going to it was already bad we had a
lot of liquidations but now the problem
is that we've wiped out 60 billion
dollars
20 billion dollars in ust is wiped it's
gone and then 60 billion dollars in the
lunar ecosystem is gone
okay there has never been a an event in
crypto where 80 billion dollars
was wiped out of the market
never
and now we're going to have to try and
get that back
and that unfortunately as as is is
is going to prolong
the winter now
it could be a month it could be three
months it could be six months
whatever happens i don't think we're
getting a v-shaped recovery where we're
gonna get to all-time highs in the next
six in the next six weeks eight weeks
forget about that
which is good
because for one
it gives you time to buy cheap prices
give you time to accumulate achieve
prices which you may never be able to
get again
two
there's no fomo anymore because how many
times did you buy [ __ ] because of
firmware because you had to buy now
because if not the coin was going to run
away from you and you know if the coin
never ran away from you
there's no fomo anymore no one
these things aren't running anywhere
yeah they might [ __ ] they're not running
anywhere you're not missing two x's and
three x's anymore they don't buy if you
remember bitcoin today at 30 733 buy
tomorrow it'll be it's 30 800 who cares
there's no more do you think it's going
lower you don't think bitcoin's going
lower
so i think today was a very interesting
day um
and let me show you this let me show
this to you again
sorry let me just decline a call which
was shouldn't have come through
let me quickly just show you this this
is an interesting thing
um i'll show you a few things which i
think you'll like
um i can't be even talking to leia about
charts but i'm going to talk to you
later
give it to me teach me okay so
here what we have today let me just
quickly make this a bit wider so we can
all see it there we go
so this is a chart of it's called the
15-minute chart what we're looking at
here is we're looking at the every
candle represents 15 minutes
so look at what happened here today
we went from 32 000 which we were on
earlier 31 700
and in half an hour when the inflation
numbers
came in
lower than last time but higher than
expectations
we wicked down
from 31.5 and we went all the way down
to 29 000 which was a key
29 000 is a key
technical level with because it's the
previous support level i'm going to bore
you with the details but
and then instead of capitulating
we recovered
it was quite interesting we recovered
and we saw the alt coins absolutely get
destroyed in that period and everyone
thought okay that's total capitulation
what we also saw in the last couple of
days
is what we call a capitulation in terms
of realized profits so what is the
capitulation in terms of realized
profits
sorry realize pro realized losses so
very often when people are in losses
they don't want to realize the losses
you say i'm a vegan lost a thousand a
very last two thousands but there comes
a point where you get to a point and say
you know what
that's it i can't do it anymore like i
can't i'm
that's it's a it's the point where you
can picture it and say you're not
[ __ ] this i can't do this anymore and
you capitulate right
and this these
sparks in the orange bar
are what you call
uh these what you're looking at here is
the number of of accounts or people
taking realizing their loss
and you can see that every time that
people have realized their losses
it's preempted a an increase
and this was we had as you can see here
a huge huge huge bunch of of of uh of
realized losses which were which were so
it's the first part of the capitulation
we could have another one tomorrow and
the next day but ultimately people are
at a point where they're giving up and
they're capitulating and that's usually
the cleanse and the beginning of a new
cycle
speaking of cycles then um wait should i
should i remove the so you yeah
yeah let us put us okay speaking of
cycles um
okay we're not going to see that
v-shaped recovery i don't really think
anybody is expecting to given the last
two years almost and how fast everything
has just exploded um but do you think
that
the market is still going to be driven
by the bitcoin halving you know these
four year cycles do you think we're
gonna we're gonna have to wait until
2024 2025 then to start seeing new
bitcoin all-time highs
so
the there is a there is a view there is
a theory of the lengthening cycle how
the cycles get longer after each harvey
and that was disproven a few days ago i
don't know if you saw benjamin khan
who's one of the the great analysts uh
technical analyst and also a great
analyst he he talks a lot about the the
four-year cycle he said look at the
lengthening cycle and that was
invalidated
what you can say for sure
is that
the
supply
of bitcoin
the reduction in the supply of bitcoin
with the increase in adoption
is is definitely going to cause
um
a price spike
however
because the spikes are becoming smaller
and smaller so like now you're mining
under 6.25 and it goes to 3.125 and it
goes to half of that
you're talking about
less and less supply but also you've got
to make an assumption around adoption
now i'm saying that now is the pit is we
are in a in adoption now this is when
we're in adoption we're not in adoption
and i don't know if the adoption is
going to increase exponentially so i
think it's going to have an effect
but i don't know if that oh just because
we're now in the next halving we're
going to all of a sudden see this this
next bull market i think that that
may have been invalidated
i'm very bullish on crypto i'm very
bullish on crypto adoption i think
crypto adoption is happening way quicker
than we could ever expect i think when
we look at things like a bitcoin
adoption but b things like nfts
like
[Music]
did you ever think if i would have come
to you a year ago leia and i would sit
here a year ago not five years ago a
year ago
like you know the biggest thing crypto
next year is actually not gonna be
bitcoin it's gonna be nfts the thing
that's gonna have the most wallet is
gonna be nfts
you would have looked at me and you
would have thought like who is this
maniac
and here we are a year later and and
nfts are today
like
insane right
that's exactly it so i think the
adoption's coming much quicker than we
think and we're going to have multiple
bull markets in crypto and i think it's
going to be different bull market from
the ones that we've seen
and you're you said you're bullish on
crypto in general and one of those one
of the networks which you've been
particularly bullish on is solana last
time we spoke i remember we had a whole
conversation about it so where are you
at with solano right now um given you
know the current price and the fact that
the network does seem to sort of get
turned on and off again
so every every blockchain had and
continues to have its problems and as
they get battle tested they fix the
problems got to remember one thing
celina's not even on a
on its real mainnet it's on a i think
it's called a test alpha i don't know
what they call it but it's it's not a
test net but it's not a main nature it's
an alpha mainnet or something like that
which is not even the mainnet and that's
pretty much a responsible approach where
they're going to keep fixing this
they're going to keep fixing this
remember that
on a network
where the fees are high
it's very hard to spam the network and
bring it to a shutdown right because if
you want to try and scan the net
ethereum network with transactions
you need a lot of money in gas it's
actually it's not worth it but at the
same time that makes ethereum unusable
because it's so expensive celina the
fees are minuscule so you want to spam
the salary network and shut it down or
stir it because the fees are like
minuscule doesn't it the reason
negligible
so
something's got to give and i think
celina will sort out its problems i
think it's got
it's an amazing piece of tech
with amazing backers so like the backers
with alameda research and multi-coin
capital and jump capital and all those
guys
insane
insane bunch of backers with great
projects working on it which actually
work and work pretty well
i know if you've seen the active
addresses on solana of late
but one thing that you may have noticed
is that there are more nft trades on
celina and more active addresses than
solana than any other blockchain and
that's more than ethereum there's more
nft there's more transactions
not in volume
but in number
oh i see
that is why obviously the big
transactions banks trading at three
million dollars are all happening on
ethereum ape
apes or trading and a million dollars
all happening on ethereum
but where is the man on the street
buying his entities
my entire office here not a single
person who works there can afford an
ethereum amenity
they're all buying teddy bears and
solana this and so on and that the real
shit's happening on solana the real
shit's happening on solano
okay what about polka dot you are
extremely bullish on polka dot when we
last spoke what's the update
um
bullish
it is an experiment
it's taking a lot longer than i thought
to take off
but it's really really really early days
my exposure to solana is much bigger
than my exposure to pokerat and because
my conviction with celana is much bigger
than my conviction with pokemon that
said
it's you gotta hedge the bit
so what are you stacking right now what
is rand doing
what am i saying i have a i'm i'm very
disciplined i have a list of things that
i want i have a
blueprint for what my portfolio needs to
look like
and right now i'm just filling in the
gaps of what's missing in my portfolio
so what i'm stacking now is not
is not what what most people should be
stacking is just what's missing in my
portfolio like for example i said i need
apecoin in my portfolio i'm willing to
i'm willing to pay five dollars for
acorn and i got it today at 5.50 so i
bought it i needed stargate in my
portfolio
i saw the price came down today so i
bought it and
and and that's that's what i'm doing
with my portfolio that doesn't mean that
everybody else needs that
what i recommend everybody
must do is they must create a blueprint
for what they want their portfolio to
look like
and then what they need to do is execute
according to their blueprint and remain
super focused and super disciplined
yeah that's the important thing you
always need to know you need to have an
exit strategy for me personally i don't
my my bitcoin i don't have an exit
strategy it's just hold forever until i
die past it on you know put it down as
cholesterol that's it everything else i
have an exit strategy for and i think
that's where people tend to go wrong
they become really greedy so can you
tell us
the top like what is rand's top five
holdings right now like you said bitcoin
was your was your biggest bag it was i
mean very simple it was uh it was
obviously luna which is now no longer
i mean it's now luna's pretty much
non-existent so
luna was my biggest bag bitcoin was my
number two bag ethereum was my number
three bags sorry solano was my number
three bag
ethereum was my number four bag four
chain is probably my number five bag
um then it goes something like near
avalanche
and then it's it keeps where it keeps
working its way down so that's pretty
much more or less what my portfolio
looks like
i have a little bit of corano uh and i
have a little link 2017 coins that i'm
holding in my portfolio but in terms of
size salina ethereum bitcoin um
avalanche avalanche near those are the
ones that in size that would have got
let's talk about avalanche um i'd love
to get your take on it because that's
sort of having the same um
kind of effect as i think it was like
solana had in terms of just like blowing
up um
in terms of different projects and
things that are being built on it right
now um they're trying to solve i think
they i don't know too much about it but
i think they call it the trifecta the
three problems security decentralization
um and then scalability do you think
they can solve this
so every blockchain is trying to solve
the same thing everybody every
blockchain wants uh security scalability
and and and uh yeah security scalability
and speed so those are the three things
that every blockchain wants to solve
avalanche is is a great piece of
technology
it is a really good piece of technology
but it's just another experiment
we won't know about this experiment
until it's really battle tested now
they're doing great things emin's a
smart guy he's doing some great things
they recently launched subnets on on
avalanche i think that may have been a
problem um i think that may have been a
slight problem
because
they allowed
if you have a subnet and a subnet for
those of you don't know what it is it's
like a
it's like a side chain almost which
plugs into the main chain to get the
congestion away from the main chain
that's basically what it is
problem is they allow people to pay the
gas
using or on the subnets using the token
of that subnet which means that there's
no real need for the avalanche token
because the only time in avalanche token
is when you're interacting with the with
the main with the main chain
right
and so
i think that they made a mistake with
those tokenomics
but i think in terms of technology it's
a very smart technology it's a multi
they don't have one chain it's actually
like you've got an a chain a beach i
don't know how they call them but
there's three chains so to speak yeah
so yeah that's that's where i mean i
think it's a great piece of tech but
it's an experiment it's a risky
experiment which may or may not work and
again we'll only know once it's been
battle tested
but a good experience
all right all right well i hold some
avax um i will always say you know
bitcoin is number one but i like to hold
some experiments it's uh it's a bear
market so i'm holding some avax and see
where it goes um regulation is coming to
the us um very hard and fast um janet
yellen has reacted to the whole
situation with ust so how do you see
regulation playing out um i think gary
gensler actually said that he sees
everything as a security other than um
bitcoin
so biden came out and i don't even
remember but he made the executive order
to regulate crypto you obviously
remember that yeah so barton came out
made the executive order to regulate
crypto in that executive order he he
said a couple of things which was super
important to note first thing he said
that one in
four households were holding crypto in
the us that's a i think you said 16
million households and that's one in
four i think that that was a number
which is huge which means that
you know the reason why people are in
crypto is because they want financial
freedom and because they think they can
make a lot of money it's that's why
they're encrypted
yeah they're all here for the tech
but they're always here for the
financial freedom because they can make
a lot of money let's not kid ourselves
so
it becomes an election issue because if
you take away something from someone
which is their hope of financial freedom
and their hope of making money then that
doesn't really serve very well for you
in the elections
so the u.s can't really be
too aggressive on the regulation
the second thing is that gary gansler
wasn't amongst the people that was asked
to regulate crypto he just wasn't on
that circuit
that memo didn't actually go to him he
wasn't part of the people that that got
the memo it wasn't him so
it was everybody else it just wasn't him
yeah
the third thing is that ever since we
got that
um
janet yellen has completely changed the
tune and in fact i heard her speaking
once
she almost sounded like she was a
blockchain lecturer she knew so much all
of a sudden
and so i think that the tone has changed
and i think there's becoming
a massive
race now
from countries
to be the home for crypto which i
wouldn't have said to you i wouldn't
have said that a year ago
so you have country cities you're living
in miami now um i think so you're
first-hand experiencing what the hell's
going on there
um
uh uh uh
uh
i mean you've got texas which is which
is pretty much also fighting in new york
which is claiming to to to want to bring
in people
claiming you're claiming you're just a
favorite
you have high taxes
do shenanigans in mining but then claim
that you want to be a crypto hub do you
i mean
yeah come on that's the favorite you're
still new york city um but then you've
got places like dubai
zero tax uh crypto regulation crypto
regulatory framework really fighting to
bring in the smart people lisbon
or
portugal
but specifically but specifically um
uh uh uh
lisbon is
attracting a whole lot of crypto people
because they've got zero taxes on crypto
so i think that
we're not going to get a lot of very
tough regulation
i think we're going to get favorable
regulation but unfortunately i do think
that regulation is going to be
it's going to protect against money
laundering
and rig and regulating against money
laundering means identifying where money
is being sent from place to place i
don't think that governments are going
to
to give up
their taxes and i don't think they're
going to give up you've got to think
from a government point of view you want
to stop a terrorist attack now if ron
and leia can send money to each other
and to terrorist organizations in the
hundreds of millions of dollars with no
repercussions and no identification on
the wallets whatsoever and they can cash
it out wherever they want
that's a problem like let's be realistic
i mean
you know
we all want bitcoin and you know we're
libertarian and whatever ultimately
listen there's going to be some kind of
regulation it's going to be more than it
is now but i think it's ultimately going
to be favorable when it happens i think
it's going to bring in a lot of money
and when it brings in a lot of money i
think everyone stands to gain
but then wall street's going to be in
our territory and they're going to do
what they have been doing in our
territory and we're going to have to
live with it
yeah it's gonna be pretty interesting so
my final my final question for you then
is the whole elon musk um saga he's soon
to own twitter um he's getting the
backing that he needs um what do you
think he's gonna do do you think he's
gonna implement doge as some kind of
tipping payments mechanism do you think
he's serious about doge
i think he's serious about doge um
because i think for him it's a game and
he wants to show that like the craziest
thing can happen and you want to just
prove to the world that when you say
something he actually does it like you
know like you know
if you're the richest man in the world
then you can buy twitter
because you just decided to buy twitter
i mean just put perspective on what's
going on here right um
uh
uh
i think he's very serious about it now
is that really good for dodge
it's not good money is it
it's not but dodge is not good
technology i think the community is
great but it's not as great as it used
to be it's not as strong as it used to
be i think since the price of deutsche
hasn't been doing so well not many
people are advocating dodge and what we
also saw is that when apecoin arrived
they all went to
apecoin so you know ultimately like i
said i think you know you want money you
want sound
store of value it's going to be bitcoin
you want money we haven't yet discovered
what the stablecoin money is we haven't
yet found a stablecoin man yet we will
find it i hoped it was going to be luna
but
unfortunately for me wasn't for a lot of
other people it wasn't
but it's it is what it is
all right ryan well you seem to be uh
recovering from the loss slowly um i
don't want to keep you much longer um i
thought you need to mourn what happened
um so i want to thank you so much for
coming on um and sharing your experience
with us i also want to thank everyone
for watching um and also please don't
forget to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss a video um and ran thank
you so much um guys please go follow
ryan if you're not already check out
crypto banter they are on every single
day um and do you have any last words
for us bran
no i think uh listen guys be strong out
there we've all been through worse we'll
recover we'll we'll get through this
crypto is not going anywhere and yeah
just keep doing what you're doing just
keep doing it for you leia thank you and
keep doing what you're doing you're
doing amazing stuff i've been watching
how you've been growing and you know i
think it's been amazing so well done and
keep doing what you're doing i
appreciate that thanks so much for
coming on guys please don't forget hit
forget to hit the subscribe button there
you go and we will see you all next week
bye bye
the latest